vous êtes sûr qu'on 24 et vous avez
raison bienvenue dans votre journal de
l'afrique à la une ce soir l'échec du
sommet de la réconciliation au burkina
faso avec deux des cinq anciens chefs
d'état l'unique président élu renversé
par les putschistes de roch marc
christian kaboré ne s'est pas rendu à
l'invitation de la suite du chef de la
junte la présence de l'ancien président
compaore arrivé ce jeudi à ouagadougou
continue de susciter la polémique nous
irons sur place dès le début de ce
journal
à la veille de la tabaski la fête du
mouton chez les musulmans à véritable
sacrifice pour de nombreuses familles en
afrique de l'ouest alors à mesure que
l'inflation gagne du terrain reportage à
suivre au sénégal où les moutons sont
hors de prix
une finale pour l'histoire la joueuse
tunisienne de tennis ons jabeur jouera
ce samedi 9 juillet la finale de
wimbledon c'est la première africaine à
parvenir en finale d'un tournoi majeur
de tennis
au lieu de 5 qu'ils étaient deux anciens
chefs d'état burkinabè autour du
président colonel putschiste d'habiba
pour cette rencontre au sommet dit de la
réconciliation l'absence de roch marc
christian kaboré l'ancien président
renversé par la junte au pouvoir a été
remarqué ses partisans n'ont pas accepté
la venue de l'ancien président blaise
compaore pour kaboré on ne peut pas
faire la réconciliation en dehors du
peuple et celle ci passe nécessairement
par la vérité et la justice les
explications de notre correspondant
abdoulaye barry
annoncé en grande pompe c'est finalement
une rencontre a minima qui se tient au
palais de kossyam sur les cinq anciens
chefs d'état annoncés ce2 blaise
compaore et jean baptiste ouédraogo ont
répondu à l'appel les trois autres ont
brillé par leur absence et yacouba isaac
candidats pour des raisons
administratives
michel kafando pour des raisons de santé
quant à roch kaboré il a été bloqué par
ses partisans qui ont corrigé dès l'aube
des barricades à son domicile pour
l'empêcher de prendre part à cette
rencontre pour tous ceux qui voient d'un
mauvais oeil cette rencontre le
lieutenant-colonel damiba rassure nous
le disons que le processus
n'est pas fait pour consacrer l'impunité
mais pour contribuer à la recherche de
solutions pour un burkina faso de paix
et de cohésion le lieutenant colonel
damiba a invité tous les anciens chefs
d'état burkinabè à se mettre au dessus
de la mêlée pour mieux incarner les
aspirations du peuple entre les
partisans de blaise compaoré qui
jubilent et les défenseurs des droits de
l'homme qui dénoncent le sacre de
l'impunité on est bien loin de l'union
sacrée pendant ce temps les burkinabè
des campagnes vive le martyre de
l'occupation jihadistes après huit ans
d'exil en côte d'ivoire blaise compaore
retourne au pays comme il en est parti
dans la controverse
les affrontements se poursuivent au nord
kivu entre l'armée congolaise et les
rebelles du m23 ceci alors que les
présidents félix éclusiers paul kagame
se sont mis d'accord mercredi à luanda
sur une désescalade on écoute le
président rwandais dans un entretien
exclusif accordé à france 24 au micro de
marc perelman
moi je me réjouis
qu'on soit tombé d'accord pour recevoir
en angola
sous les auspices du président lorenzo
de l'angola
et on a eu de bonnes discussions
de côté
d'après ce que j'ai pu voir
chercher
à progresser
et ce jeudi le porte parole du mouvement
a déclaré que le m23 n'était pas
concerné par l'arrêt des hostilités les
détails avec notre correspondant rdc
qu'est montbenon
il n'aura fallu que quelques heures pour
que les violences reprennent entre
l'armée congolaise et les m23 malgré l'
annonce d'une désescalade à l'issue du
mini sommet de luanda mercredi jeudi tôt
dans la matinée des combats ont éclaté
autour de rumangabo sur la route qui
relie coma harrouch roues et ce vendredi
des affrontements ont également été
signalés à rousset qui à quelques
dizaines de kilomètres poussan de
nouveau des centaines de civils à fuir
interrogé jeudi le porte parole du n 23
ou line goma a estimé que la feuille de
route décidée à luanda ne concernait pas
son mouvement nous sommes des congolais
pas des rwandais at il déclaré s'il ya
un cessez-le-feu cela ne peut être
contre nous et le gouvernement congolais
des propos qui ont fait réagir les
autorités congolaises qui accuse je le
rappelle le rwanda de soutenir la
rébellion le ministre des affaires
étrangères christophe lutundula ainsi
reproché au m23 de chercher à mentir la
rdc dans un état d'ingouvernabilité et
d'instabilité pour rappel mercredi lé
président tshisekedi et kagame se sont
mis d'accord pour normaliser les
relations diplomatiques entre leurs deux
pays après les tensions de ces derniers
mois la feuille de route de luanda
prévoit notamment le retrait du m23 de
ses positions rdc ainsi que la cessation
immédiate des hostilités
l'ancien président de l'angola est
décédé aujourd'hui à l'âge de 79 ans
josé eduardo dos santos avait régné
d'une main de fer pendant 38 ans avant
de céder la place révolutionnaire à
l'aide à l'époque de la guerre il
restera dans l'histoire pour cette
affaire de corruption d'une vaste
ampleur du népotisme et d'abus des
droits de l'homme sophie lamothe
c'est ici qu'il a passé ces derniers
jours dans un hôpital privé de barcelone
révolutionnaire marxiste dans ses débuts
politiques il prend les armes contre le
colonisateur portugais à l'âge de 16 ans
quelques années plus tard le mouvement
de libération d'angola devient un parti
politique et dos santos prend la tête du
gouvernement en 1979
il joue un rôle décisif dans la fin de
la guerre civile angolaise en 2002 ce
qui lui vaut le titre d'architecte de la
paix auprès de ses supporters
nous poursuivrons le travail commencé
par notre défunt président agostinho
neto le travail que le président dos
santos lui même a poursuivi
son nom est néanmoins aussi associée à
la corruption
malgré son immense richesse pétrolière
l'angola reste l'un des pays les plus
inégalitaires au monde plus de deux
tiers de sa population vit sous le seuil
de pauvreté pour cause d'après
l'opposition corruption endémique et
népotisme sous dos santos
une enquête de la fia e-jets les loups
en d'alix démontre notamment l'étendue
des détournements de fonds et corruption
de sa fille en 2020 isabel dos santos un
jour la femme la plus riche d'afrique
avec un patrimoine estimé à plus de 2
milliards de dollars
le président a privatisé l'état en
faveur de sa famille et de ses proches
pour ces individus il s'agit d'avoir les
ressources à leur disposition
d'avoir le même style de vie que les
personnes les plus riches du monde sans
se soucier de ce que vit le peuple
sa mort survient à un moment
particulièrement sensible pour le pays
qui se prépare à des élections générales
en août 2022 malgré les relations
tendues entre lourenço et la famille dos
santos le président actuel décrète un
deuil national de cinq jours en sa
mémoire
ce week-end les musulmans du monde
entier célèbreront l'aïd el kabir aussi
appelée tabaski en afrique de l'ouest et
pour l'occasion la coutume veut que le
chef de famille sacrifier un mouton une
gageur cette année à cause d'une
inflation record les bêtes pouvant
coûter jusqu'à 30% plus cher dans
plusieurs points de vente comme à dakar
la capitale sénégalaise reportage de
samra puisse et maintenant
mokhtar ne va pas acheter le mouton
cette année cet agent de sécurité et
père de deux enfants gagne 80 mille
francs cfa environ 120 euros par mois
une somme inférieure au prix moyen de
moutons au sénégal il compte sur la
solidarité familiale pour passer une
bonne fête
salaire n'est pas assez élevé pour me
permettre d'acheter en mouton pour ma
famille cette année je vais m'associer
avec des amis qui ont un meilleur
pouvoir d'achat pour acquérir un bélier
ensemble pour la fête
le prix des moutons a flambé ces
derniers mois dans ce point de vol de
l'appareil de dakar il faut marchander
pour en acquérir 10
impensable pour moi
l'année dernière j'ai acheté mon mouton
à 150 mille francs cfa cette année pour
un mouton de la même taille il faut
compter entre 200000 et 300 mille francs
cfa
certains récits tout est devenu cher
toutes les deux au nigeria par blaye y
apparaissent donc l'alimentation coûte
cher sa cause d'alimentation le ministre
de l'élevage assure que la demande
totale de moutons pour la fête évalué à
8,5 10 mille têtes sera entièrement
satisfaite il estime que les
consommateurs seront tous servis je suis
en train d'interpeller le consommateur
pour lui dire que le ministère travaille
pour que qu'il y ait une fourchette de
prix aussi large que possible pour que
toutes les troupes toutes les bouches
tous les budgets puisse trouver des
moutons correspondant à leur niveau et
c'est ça qui est important le ministère
de l'élevage assure avoir subventionné
le coût de l'alimentation des moutons à
plus de 60% de nombreux éleveurs assure
n'avoir pas pu bénéficier de cette aide
elle fait la fierté de tous les
africains la tunisienne ons jabeur
discutera ce samedi 9 juillet sa
première finale de grand chelem sur le
court central de wimbledon à 27 ans elle
est la première joueuse africaine et
arabe à parvenir en finale d'un tournoi
majeur de tennis florent rodo
les tunisiens la surnomme la ministre du
bonheur 11 jabeur est désormais une
source de joie quasi intarissable pour
son pays jeudi sur le court central de
wimbledon la droitière a battu
l'allemande tatjana maria en trois sets
devenant ainsi la première joueuse de
tennis du continent africain hommes et
femmes confondus à atteindre la finale
d'un tournoi du grand chelem à 27 ans
elle veut servir d'exemple au maroc
tunisie nous sommes si fiers d'être
tunisienne et je sais qu'en tunisie
aujourd'hui ça doit être la faute
j'essaie d'être une source d'inspiration
pour le plus de gens possible je veux
voir de plus en plus de tunisiens mais
pas que plus de joueurs arabes et
africains sur le circuit
première joueuse arabes aussi à entrer
dans le top 10 était l'an dernier 11
jabeur a remporté début mai son premier
tournoi majeur à madrid
aujourd'hui classé numéro deux mondial
elle fait la fierté de son peuple
on jabeur donne une superbe image de la
tunisie et l envoie aussi un message aux
jeunes lorsqu'on se fait confiance et
qu'on se fixe un objectif dans la vie on
peut l'atteindre
une victoire finale ce samedi sur le
gazon londonien face à la kazakhe elena
riba qui n'a hélas tunisienne
basculerait définitivement dans une
autre dimension elle qui est d'ores et
déjà l'ambassadrice mondiale numéro un
du tennis africain
et c'est ainsi que nous refermons ce
journaleux l'afrique merci à tous ceux
qui nous ont suivis de dakar à niamey en
passant par conakry bonne tabaski à tous
est resté avec nous car l'actualité
continue sur france inter
[Musique]